when I talk about the finite the the
finite trend that the trend towards
finite mindedness in business over the
past you know 30 40 years you you can
show the exact same correlation in
politics where politics and politicians
have become more short-term focused and
more finite minded as well and just like
in businesses we become more focused on
the product rather than the vision so to
have politicians become more focused on
a single issue or a single idea rather
than the context within which that idea
exists I haven't it's not that those
ideas are right or wrong or good or bad
my question is to what end
like what vision does that idea serve
because the ideas that they propose or
strategies the strategies to get towards
something get towards what and what's
missing from all of our politicians for
and this is not a Republican or Democrat
thing this has been for years well its
mission from missing from all of our
politicians is distant idealized sort of
inspirational vision whether you're a
Democrat or a Republican you could have
listened to Ronald Reagan's inaugural
address or you could have listened to
john f kennedy's inaugural address and
they both talked about world peace peace
on earth like even saying those words
now sounds ridiculous but that's a
wonderful thing to talk about the dream
i have a dream of a distant future that
we should commit ourselves to work
towards one slow step at a time and i
think what's missing from all of them is
they're hoping to garner favor by people
who like the one idea because it
resonates with me and they're trying to
pick the idea that resonates with the
most people so they can get elected and
it's not that the ideas are right or
wrong but i want to know to what end
what's the bigger vision
[Music]